CNN is suing the Trump administration
over the white house credential
suspension for the channels chief White
House reporter Fox News media analysts
and host of Fox's media buzz Howard
Kurtz on what's at stake for the
president and the press CNN is taking
action after the White House ban our
chief White House correspondent Jim
Acosta CNN's contentious relationship
with President Trump moved into court
today its lawsuit came after the White
House yanked the credentials of Acosta
who has a history of lecturing and
confronting the president following this
clash at a news conference that's enough
that's one of the other folks that said
now pardon me ma'am mr. president that's
enough I'll tell you what CNN should be
ashamed of itself having you working for
them you are a rude terrible person
Sarah Huckabee Sanders called the suit
more grandstanding from CNN which she
says has nearly 50 other credentialed
staffers after Acosta asked two
questions she said he physically refused
to surrender a White House microphone to
an intern so that other reporters might
ask their questions and that this wasn't
the first time he acted inappropriately
that's not great Sanders didn't repeat
the administration's highly disputed
contention that Acosta had laid hands on
the intern the move cast CNN president
Jeff Zucker the former NBC chief who
worked with Trump on The Apprentice as a
press champion he says the First
Amendment gives journalists the right to
hold officials accountable and ask tough
questions we're asking for emergency
relief because every day that this pass
has been revoked is a First Amendment
violation and it's irreparable harm in
the words of the law the suit notes the
president constantly criticizes the
network CNN's fake news questions from
standing and once tweeted this wrestling
video aimed at CNN the White House
Correspondents Association is backing
CNN but Acosta is a controversial figure
viewed by some colleagues as a showboat
and CNN soup may convince many Trump
backers that the network is part of the
opposition Brett how our thanks